your whole thing about the climate
change oh gee climate change i'm not
even gonna go and argue the the
scientific
argument
i'm not your solution right now is to
tell me we stop all carbon emission we
stop all fossil fuels right now
right now
but jordan what does that mean if we did
that what does that mean if we did that
it means it means poor people will
freeze in the dark and bake in the sun
while they starve thank you you just
signed a death
warrant for 1.3 billion people of them
one billion black people and you just
told me that black lives matter
so even when you come to climate you're
full of it
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased today to be
talking to ms magat wade who's known for
advocating for a prosperous innovative
africa through entrepreneurship and
economic freedom
she is the founder of
skinisskin.com a skin care company that
manufactures in africa and sells
products in the us
and as a practicing and successful
african entrepreneur
can bring her experience to the table
when discussing obstacles to doing
business in africa as compared to the us
magot has concluded that those who
purport to care about black africans
should support free markets and
affordable and reliable energy including
fossil fuels
her forthcoming book the heart of a
cheetah available soon through
magatwade.com
will provide detailed suggestions for
how to accelerate progress for africans
she is a blunt straight talker who has
little patience for the anti-capitalists
pieties favored by many so-called allies
of black people
thank you very much for agreeing to talk
to me today
thanks for having me jordan it's a
pleasure being here
so let's start with a bit of your
history
in your let's talk about your company
and where it's founded and how you
managed to establish it and what sort of
obstacles you did face
sure
so it's whenever someone asks me my god
tell me about your story um i start i
take you back to
where i was born and uh
in senegal the west coast of africa and
there i primarily really my story
started with
when my parents um right around age two
i was done with breastfeeding my mother
decided that it was time for her and my
father to go and seek better pastures
you know uh to afford us a better life
back home and that's when they made the
journey that so many africans make you
know to um provide for better life for
their families and it's at the time
where they decided to migrate from
senegal
to europe unfortunately many people have
made the same journey before them and
after them many unfortunately did not
make it under as good circumstances as
they did because they could do it in a
legal way which means you can take legal
pathways and routes that are not as
dangerous as others so my parents become
economic migrants like many other
africans before them and after them
uh went to europe and of course you know
managed to build a very good life for
themselves um and so they left me behind
to be with my grandmother and right
around age seven
it was time for me to be reunited with
the family unit um that my my father and
mother have you know constitute and so
the it was decided now you're going to
se to germany and jordan i will never
ever forget when i first sat foot on
that continent in that country my first
time ever leaving my village
and i just remember being like wait a
second how come they have that and we
don't
and that was
i was just looking around you know
all of these paved streets compare that
to
unpaved streets back home walking i'm
walking around my feet are always dusty
ashy always have to wash them back when
i go home
uh how come they have that meaning you
know back home when it's uh to get a
shower my grandma would have to heat a
pot of hot water put it you know on the
stove and when i say stove
it's not you know you go into your
kitchen and you turn the stove and you
know the burner comes on no no it's like
she's establishing like a little um
a little stove literally that's off of
the ground
just like when you go camping you know
where you put the charcoal so puts a
charcoal in has to get it going and then
she put the pot of water on it then it
boils and then we bring a bigger bucket
put that hot water mix some cold water
to it and then
um one of my cousins stronger would drag
it to the shower area and there with a
smaller pot i would then for
go on to have my shower compare that now
to germany my mom is like my god time to
shower i'm like so you mean i jump in
there and i turn the knobs on
you know this one this one and then the
water comes down at the temperature i
need it and all of that took
a blink of an eye to happen are you
kidding me if when you walk into the
stores everything is acid in the in the
summer um heat it in the in the in the
winter it's just like this ease of life
i think that's what as a little girl i
was seeing this ease of life what are
you talking about and so eventually that
question of a little girl
of
how come they have this and we don't
became with time how come some countries
like mine senegal and other many african
nations are poor while nations like the
united states france oh they're rich how
come how come some nations are poor
while others are rich and it's a
question that never left me and it
defined my life that question defined my
life well so let's walk through that
because that is a crucial question
i read a
book a while back by a harvard
professor emeritus
called the wealth and poverty of nations
and it addresses that very question and
one of the surprising conclusions he
comes to
is that a huge part of what makes some
countries rich and other countries poor
is the presence of an almost universal
trust in matters of trading and so for
him i think his name was landis the most
valuable natural resource is actually
trust
and i would say also a bit of lack of
envy because
with envy it makes it impossible for
anyone to have anything because everyone
else is jealous and angry about it and
well that's one
of the pathways let's say to wealth what
have you concluded i mean you've been
thinking about this your whole life ever
since you went to germany when you were
seven right right so i've been thinking
about it my whole life and looking for
answers my whole life
and as i was growing up and moving
around you know
i
you know i heard it from some very
people who with a straight face will
invoke the iq fury or darling it's not
your fault you see you know because in a
world where you being black um it there
is a fury out there that you're just not
as smart as white people i've gone to
conferences where i heard there was
panels
and people
talking and making that case
um i heard people say oh darling it's
just because you know malnutrition you
know you guys are just not well
nourished and just because you know
others say oh if only if you had access
to greater education
and i'm like you go say that
to the countless young africans in my
country senegal you know the joke is the
first job of a graduate is to be a
street seller
how many of these people on the street
you see them hustling in between cars in
a very dangerous way under the hot sun
and you ask them what did you study and
they're trying to tell you i have
i have an mba in finance in math and
they're right there doing what they're
doing i was just talking to um a person
in uh sweaty land in eswatini it used to
be called swaziland i mean beautiful
math background and i said what are you
doing now because i'm considering hiring
her remotely and she said well i'm
raising chickens
all she can do right now is raising
chickens so if you're going to make it
about education you go talk to those
people first and you and you come back
and talk to me about it um and then
other people just oh
maybe if i give you some free shoes if i
give you some shoes you'll you'll be
better off tom's shoes buy some shoes so
that some other people have a better
life all of this nonsense jordan i've
been hearing throughout times but guess
what none of them made any sense to me
because if you're gonna make it also
about um let's say even use the iq which
i should not even give a minute to
but com then how come the same person
same background same education let's
take even my parents
all of a sudden they make it to europe
and voila they can manifest their
greatest potential so i'm starting to
think maybe it's not about this person
maybe there's something else that's not
about this person per se in this
situation and then i'm like maybe it has
to do with a place they get to be in or
not
and so
that was starting to brew in my head so
as all of this is happening i'm living
my little life i from germany couple
years later my family decided we're
going to move to france if we're going
to stay in europe for many reasons
because you know france used to be the
color um
senegal is an ex-colony of france and
then after my business school in france
i decided that france was going to be
too small for my ambitions i got to get
out of here i don't want to be in a
country where you have to be if you make
it to the right school your kids are
right behind for the right amount of
time then you can hope maybe for some
type of promotion no battle is not for
me i'm not saying that everybody does
that but it was just not a good a good
option for me so i i looked around and i
could go anywhere literally as i wanted
and i thought about the united states
this one country where you can anyone
can become anything they want as long as
they put in the work and if that's what
they desire to do and so i came to the
us and when i came to us i was first a
headhunter in finance in the silicon
valley in the heydays of a.com i used to
go to netflix when netflix was this tiny
office in san jose google when most
people didn't even know how to pronounce
google was one little building um in the
silicon valley and so there i got to see
all of this entrepreneurship happening
and so jordan this is where at some
point something happened and i'm taking
a little detour here but this detour is
so important because it will you i will
i will get you to my answer but it's
because it's right there so
while i was in silicon valley i was
pretty much steeped into what they call
the ecosystem of the entrepreneur and
just this idea of two people getting
together they have an idea of writing in
the back of a napkin this was it sounds
cliche but i lived it i've seen it and
uh when they go to a lawyer to start
their business to start you know them
the company legally find some investors
and this whole ecosystem that comes
around them
and then i start to be like wow this is
rather amazing and i think it's in
silicon valley but i discovered the
magic of entrepreneurship is to create
something out of nothing and that to me
was so powerful so powerful i was living
it in my bones and from there right but
as you as you pointed out there are a
lot of moving parts in that system
aren't there because absolutely you need
you need people who have an
entrepreneurial vision and who think of
themselves that way
and then you need a group of people
around you like that to talk to and then
you need early stage financers who are
often friends and family who are willing
to contribute time effort money and then
you need later stage financing and there
is a whole and the ability to work with
customers and the willingness to market
and sell and so all of these pieces have
to fall into place before anything like
prosperity can can back up and come back
okay so you
you encountered this in silicon valley
and what did that do to you yeah so i
encountered it
but just before you go uh when you were
talking about the early investment in
your family and your friends we like to
talk about the three f's family friends
and fools so the fools are very useful
there so in any case um so here i am in
silicon valley and you know and i was
doing extremely well for myself um at
age 25 i was making six figures both uh
my home with a pool in one of the most
expensive zip codes in america and i say
it more for what can happen uh in this
country i could never ever have dreamed
of such a life in such a young age being
who i am in back in back home in france
so um right there you know the
the american dream does exist it was
real for me an immigrant from africa so
but you know uh jordan with all of that
success um
[Music]
one day i lost it uh one day i was
driving down big sur one of the most
beautiful
roads we asked me in the world with
highway one highway one with a passenger
man it's something eh it's so beautiful
you you cannot not believe in god when
you're on that path okay that's how
beautiful it is
especially if you're taking hairpin
corners in a convertible yes yes
absolutely and you know jordan it was
one of his moments that day was one of
those days when the sun was as usual
shining the ocean was beautiful i was um
you know listening to some houston doer
in my car great [ __ ] musician and just
just feeling just feeling so much
gratitude and also so much pride in
myself for what i was able to accomplish
and so much gratitude for everyone and
everything that helped me get there
and just
as many times just like it happens every
time i got to that moment of bliss
right away my mood turned
this everything became dark
as it usually does because why because
right at that moment
i started thinking about the people that
i had left back home
and
it happened often times prove it
throughout time through my life for my
life you know because how how else
do you feel
when you're growing up
and you hear your parents or you read
the news you hear the news and it's
saying that
a body
dropped from a plane somewhere above
england
because someone decided to migrate
right to europe for a better life just
like my parents did but they did it
again under better conditions and they
thought it would be a good idea to hide
into a landing the landing gear but
somewhere above you know
london above england the body falls or
they open the plane and they find the
cargo section of a plane a frozen body
somebody thought it would be a good idea
to hide in the cargo section of a plane
no one told them it gets so cold up
there
or you know this boat just tipped
this little fisherman's boat just
stepped up you know
somewhere along between the coast of
senegal and spain
which is the first entry into europe for
these people but the boat tipped over it
is not equipped to make this journey
and in the boat you have babies you have
young people primarily young people
and these are some of our most
entrepreneurial people the people that
we need to build the prosperity back
home
and where are we now lying at the bottom
of the ocean serving as fish food
how else would you feel if for years
growing up these are the stories
that you have
you're hearing and yet why do you why do
you think your conscience bothered you
at that point i mean you had been yeah
you had been you come to the states you
you become successful you had this
beautiful day and so why all of a sudden
do you suppose your thoughts turned to
the people that had been left behind so
to speak i mean it wasn't your fault
that they were in the state they were
you know yeah i know it wasn't my fault
for sure it took me a long time to
accept that it wasn't my fault
uh so what happened that day is i no
longer was able to play the
schizophrenia game but i played my whole
life i was no able no longer able to the
coping mechanism that i had developed up
till then no longer was holding
uh the coping mechanism that i had
developed back for all of these years
was as soon as i started thinking about
it i would like to tell myself
this is not your fault you you have a
life to live it is not fair yeah i i
would tell myself all of his stories and
then i would just shrug it under the rug
act as if it
but that day
for some bizarre reason it just no
longer worked and i lost it i lost it my
butt it was the feeling was so violent
that my body jerked literally and it's a
miracle that i'm talking to you because
it might my body jerks so much that with
the steering wheel and i was gonna end
up down below in that ocean but for some
reason it didn't and as soon as i found
a spot to stop i stopped and i got out
of the car
something major had happened i still
don't explain what it was but at that
time jordan i surrendered
i surrendered i said god from here on
i'm showing up
and i promise you and i want you to help
me
make sure that every breath i take from
here on
is gonna go towards the bettering of my
continent
right
i just made that deal with god i said
this is what i i'm showing up for this i
present and i offer myself
this is why did you think why did you
think this was
between you and god so to speak
because it was so big
it was so big
and um
it was so big and he's the only one that
i trusted to help me with that
the only one
and most importantly i had no idea what
to do about it
but i knew that faith
would be my best ally in this until i
could figure it out yeah well faith
faith sometimes is the courage to do
difficult things
you know what it's a very good way to
look at it and maybe maybe that's what
happened that day because that day i was
definitely not not willing or let i say
not capable at least of being a coward
about it anymore because my whole life i
was pretty cowardish about it if you
think about mike how why why cowardly
why would you say that about yourself
i don't know it's just because
um
the idea that in order to no longer feel
the pain i would have to push it under
the rug
i don't find that very i don't find that
very courageous
but i didn't know what else to do
because otherwise the pain was just
going to drag me into places but at
least i had the sanity to know where not
safe or healthy for me until i knew how
to get into those dark spaces right
which by the way i learned afterwards
because afterwards i used uh knowledge
to my rescue
understanding really helped settle
everything yeah well it is a terrible
thing it is a terrible thing to look on
the poverty and the corruption let's say
of an entire continent and
in some sense the entire world and to
contrast that with your own prosperity
and then to realize at least in
principle that you have a moral duty to
do something about it that's exactly
that's no trivial undertaking that's
exactly okay so so you're on the side of
the road and you've pulled over and
you've had this realization so continue
yeah so i pulled on the side of a road i
had this realization
and eventually
um i said from here on this is the path
i'm taking and i want you to help me so
show me the way i will i will be a good
a good disciple
and so
and these things started to change
with um and it started with few months
later
uh my um husband
who was french and i talked about him in
the past tense because poor soul he
passed away
um shortly after you know after all of
this like we barely we had
maybe a year together i didn't know that
then but um i took him home to senegal
to see the place i came from and there
he was asking me about this hibiscus
beverage i've been telling him about
forever you know you know how how it is
when you're not from the same culture
but the first thing you teach whatever
is what you love about your respective
cultures and that's how a better culture
is born out of that mixing in any case
we're there and it's like where
i want to try biscuits you're talking
about so you know everywhere we go
at the restaurant or within my friends
fam or friend and family homes you go
there and they off they bring you to
this plate
coke fanta pepsi
i'm like where is the hibiscus
girl where have you been so basically
what happens is what has happened
anybody who feels like is a somebody
drinks the western soda pop brands the
ones i just talked about and and the
bottom of a pyramid which is the bulk of
the people they bring they drink
knockout brands knock out those knockout
brands and in between the traditional
indigenous drink that we used to have is
squeezed out and with them the
livelihood of the women who are
primarily the ones who used to grow the
raw material which is the hibiscus so
now these women are leaving the
countryside going and packing themselves
in the cities and there you know
begging on streets um prostitution maybe
working in people's homes where they're
being treated horribly so anyway this
cycle of poverty is just keeping going
and and there
i thought i was done with with being
depressed sometimes about the situation
back home
i fell in a
literal depression
i for three days my body my body was not
willing to obey me anymore it was just
like i'm done i was so disappointed with
the world because now here i am not only
do i have my people now dying but now i
also have my culture dying because
my hibiscus drink which is called bisa
bisap is called it's the juice of
taranga taranga means hospitality that
is what the people of senegal are known
for so this is a part of our cultural
identity yet it is not on that plate
that they brought me so when i think of
a plate i think of a world stage and
when i think of a drinks on it i think
of the cultures of a world that matter
so much but they're on that plate well
what am i seeing i'm not there and
that's a big problem because if you're
not there it means your culture is
disappearing and if your culture
disappears the only time people might
remember me in the future in museums
why do you use the metaphor of the table
you know what i never thought about it
i don't know it's just something that
came to my mind when i saw that it was
just like i saw that plate i sow the
drinks on it and it was just our world
was right there the plate so it's a
divine symbol right that that's an
ancient divine symbol that that
in some sense the the collective table
the table of the gods to have a seat at
the table is to be part of the
conversation and to be part of the elect
in some real sense you know to be
welcomed in with hospitality and to
share and to distribute and to
mutually enjoy that's a very very old
idea it's very very striking to me that
that that that that was the metaphor
that sprung to mind because we want
everyone to come to the table don't we
that's the plan we do and that's the
plan absolutely that's a very good point
i never made the connection but now that
you're bringing it up it makes it it it
does make perfect sense actually
interesting
okay yeah that's for sure that's for
sure interesting well you you know you
you started that part of our
conversation with a bit of an
introduction to a religious experience
that you had while you were driving and
the fact that that
uh table metaphor popped up there makes
perfect sense from a symbolic
perspective you know you also want the
table to be laden with
with the finest of produce right and you
want it to be a place of plenty and
generosity as well as hospitality and
and an invitation to everyone to enjoy
that's all part of life more abundant
and that's right bringing everyone to
the economic table is a way of of moving
forward towards that goal that's right
okay so the hibiscus tank that really
bothered you yes so
so
i got ill
for three days i was just shut down i
could not move anymore i was pissed off
i was disappointed i was sad i was
depressed
and my husband's like my god
this anger of yours it's energy but it's
negative energy you've got to find a way
to turn it around into positive energy
when it becomes inspiration and then you
use it to fuel yourself
and with with that
and this
old concept i grew up with of uh
criticized by creating it's
michelangelo's but that's very much the
rules under which i was raised
i don't need you to have a right answer
you know my grandma or my father would
say but i need to know that you have
fought of alternatives they don't have
to be the right ones but i want to know
that you have thought of the right of
solutions because when you're in
solutions mode you no longer are a
victim you've it's a completely
different mindset and i think that's
more what they're doing well you know
the other thing that's interesting about
that too i think is that first of all i
think that's a good rule of thumb but
also
people have problems and they're often
annoyed and oppressed by the fact they
have problems but first of all you don't
have all the problems in the world you
have your problems and the problems that
bother you and you might ask yourself
well why do those problems bother you
and not other problems and i would say
maybe it's because in those problems you
actually find your destiny and those are
often things you don't want to look at
like you didn't want to look at the
poverty of your of your continent and no
bloody wonder who wants to look at that
but it was something that bothered you
it turned out that was your problem and
if you faced it well then you figured
out on that road that that was your
destiny properly thinking properly
speaking yes and it was not always easy
for me to recognize that or to see it as
clearly as i do today but yes if i did
not follow that if i don't if i did not
pursue that question i would not be
sitting here talking to you right now
because there would be no reason for for
it so
so there um we've criticized by creating
turn this anger
up
energy into positive energy into
inspiration then i'm starting to come
back to life i'm like you know what yeah
if i've got a problem with this
situation i gotta fix it myself so i'm
gonna start a company i'm gonna start a
brand
and we're to sell it first in the u.s
because i'm going to do reverse
colonialism on my people if the only
time they can respect something is if
the west has said oh now we welcome it
then i'm going to trick you the same way
hoping that the second generation the
next generation that comes after you
luckily for them they won't need that
type of validation because they were
born in a world in which they were
just fine in a world in which they were
the it people right so but this is a
detour i need to take let's take it
so with that i just became very
galvanized and so we started this
business and my whole thing was i'm
going to start a brand i don't want to
start an ngo telling people you should
respect africans or you should respect
this ingredient or these poor women are
listening no build a brand because brand
have such a power to influence culture
and i was dealing here with a cultural
issue first and foremost and so build a
company
hire people back home
and um make the brand pop in the u.s and
then you have your virtual circle where
the jobs are created back home and your
culture also takes its rightful place at
the table and that's exactly what that's
exactly what we did i started this
company in my kitchen and eventually by
the time you look around you have on my
board roger enrico the ex-chairman of
pepsico you have a german gentleman who
started you know sobe that was sold to
us to
pepsi and then also adwala which was
sold to um coca-cola so all of these
who's who of the business of
the beverage world we're sitting at my
table helping me run this company again
something like this i could never have
done this
if i was not in this country
so this is where we are now but you know
what jordan then what happened there i
was starting to get my answers
because as we built this company the
sister company was based in senegal and
it was mostly for the supply chain side
and then another sister company was
built in the u.s for more marketing uh r
d
sales and um sales for sales channels
that's what a sister company was doing
and would you know that as i was
building this company at least back then
it took it would take you a quick 20
minutes maybe faster depending on how
fast you type
to establish an llc online
compare that to the compare that to
almost two years
it took me
to legally register the sister company
in senegal
right so let's let's just let's just
focus on that for a minute
okay so you're comparing
20 minutes
to two years
right so then you have to ask yourself
and i'm sure you have
is how much time and energy do people
have like it's not an easy thing to set
up a business it's a daring thing and
there's a tremendous amount of risk
involved and you'll probably fail that's
the risk faster now you might succeed
beyond your wildest dreams but if you
exhaust all your hard-working and
entrepreneurial people by forcing them
to jump through idiot hoops non-stop all
that you do is keep people absolutely
impoverished and so that we've got a key
issue with regard to poverty right here
which is the presence of a stunning
amount of unnecessary red tape so how is
it do you think that the u.s has managed
to make it so that you can register a
company
in 20 minutes whereas in senegal it
takes two years and you know i read a
great book called uh the mystery of
capital hernando de soto i was gonna
bring him up yeah yeah yeah desoto is
great man that's a great book
he points out that in some of the
so-called developing countries
especially the more corrupt ones not
only does it take multiple years to do
anything at all legally but by the time
you jump through all the hoops to do it
legally the laws have been changed so
that what you do is no longer valid that
is absolutely that is absolutely the
case so you're asking me a very good
question
and the way i will go about that is
there i'm gonna try to take this
opportunity to debunk a myth because
this whole conversation with you
i take it as my opportunity to debunk so
many myths about african poverty
hence
what would it take for africans
to build african prosperity because i'm
not interested in alleviating poverty
i'm not interested in just like oh can i
be a little bit less poor no
i want to be prosperous i think my
people like anybody else should be
prosperous
yes and we should also point out let's
point out very clearly since we're
debunking myths that that's actually a
high ethical aim is that we want life
more abundant for everyone we don't want
to limp along lowering our carbon
footprint barely scraping the surface we
want people to be prosperous and free
and life to be abundant and everyone to
have enough educational resources and to
thrive and that's the ethical aim that's
right
to thrive human flourishing to me it
starts and it ends with it human
flourishing now what it means for
somebody to flourish it's going to be up
to them to decide but do
should everybody have a
access to human flourishing you betcha
so
here i going back to the question and
why the u.s and in africa not and then
hernando de soto uh making the case that
oftentimes corrupt countries um make it
so hard so
there
i the myth that i debunk is so often you
know i talk to people and they're like
oh africa these countries it's this
region is so corrupt and i'm like yes um
my country
might be corrupt
almost as bad as chicago
you know what i mean by that so
corruption is if if you will everywhere
but
the way it manifests itself is different
from place to place and so i would like
to argue on the order
uh and the relationship between
corruption and
these laws that hernando de soto was
talking about the more of a corrupt and
the more you have to jump through hoops
and everything
i like to argue that corruption is a
cause of senseless
loss
is a cause
too many laws and also senseless laws
when you have those together then you
breed you you breed corruption
give you an example this is another
example that we had to go through
my current company is a skincare company
skinny skin so for that we have to
import some ingredients because if you
don't have them
you need your uh to imp to imp you need
the inputs that you need at the standard
of quality that you need them in order
to remain
competitive in your marketplace my
marketplace is the united states that's
where people have the money to spend all
of this to spend on our products uh they
understand our products this is just
it's one of the best markets for us for
many different reasons um we sell at
companies we sell at places like whole
foods market i don't have to tell you
it's one of the most beautiful chains of
grocery stores in the u.s you can
imagine that the buyers are super
sophisticated and they don't just bring
any product in that's in that chain
but they bring us so which tells you the
level of standard we're playing at with
world class world class so it means that
everything behind the scene has to be
world class the whole chain up and down
has to be world class and so ingredients
no different so we have to bring in some
ingredients
well guess what jordan for some of my
ingredients the tariff is 45
to enter the country 45
others
almost 70 percent
how do you expect me to be um
competitive if you're slapping such
tariff on some of my inputs how because
for every 50 cents you add on tariffs i
have to sell my products two dollars
more than i would have in order for me
to actually make it
i become very uncompetitive very quickly
quality for quality product for the
product so
there we had to uh so now if instead of
making it a 45
how about maybe it's a zero percent like
it is in the u.s when i have if i had to
bring the same product here in the us
zero percent tariff on it um or make it
five percent or two percent three
percent something that makes sense so
when do you really think that i'm going
to try to jump through the hoops of
avoiding about 45 percent over 70
percent
raise no need pay
pay it and move on because you've got
better things to do
see see how bad laws
and senseless laws
breed corruption because people will
then
it is cheaper and faster for people to
pay the bribe and move on than to adhere
to the law you see so that's what we
have inherited in most african nations
as i noticed
the discrepancy and the difference
between doing business back home
and doing business in the united states
at first i was like well of course it's
like this it's just because you know
we're poor nation we're messed up and
that's why that's why everything else is
messed up
and then eventually
i started to really think about it to
think it through and it's around the
same time that god again brought some
interesting people
in my life because at that time
my company my first company at least was
um
you know now i had moved into the
non-profit we had started a non-profit
because my goal was how can i help
replicate whatever success i was able to
have how can i help many of my guts or
my male counterparts from africa do
exactly what i did with whatever product
they deem to do it with
how could i help with that
and it is during that journey that i
eventually even learned about the work
of hernando de soto and when i heard
about his work he was right there
telling me my god what you went through
what you're going through experientially
experientially speaking is not an
anecdote
this is very very something very
systemic about this and it is called
economic freedom
how easy or hard it is to do a business
you have indexes that measure this the
most known of them being the doing
business index ranking of a world bank
and then you have a frazier institute um
economic freedom index as well and
others and offers well what do they all
have in common they all show you one
after the other
that it is harder to do business in
anywhere in sub-saharan africa
than it is anywhere in scandinavia and i
stick scandinavia purposely because
people who are anti-business
you know
they need to know
that scandinavia is more business
friendly
is more pro-capitalist i'll use a dirty
word than almost any sub-saharan african
nation
and very right and so the scandinavian
choice is a very interesting one because
the rabid and idiot anti-capitalists of
the west often point to scandinavia as
socialist countries but yeah as you can
point out they're well they're socialist
on the edges and capitalists at the core
and in a very very effective and
efficient manner and so they are
business friendly and precisely the
manner that you described and those
those uh
principles that you elucidated minimum
necessary laws that's part of the
english common law tradition um minimum
necessary force of enforcement that's
another good one yeah and and
um
well and
what is it clear and maintained and you
also have clear and transfer and
transferable property rights
and you also have the concept of a rule
of law as well
right right right so so those are the
some of the metaphysical and legislative
substrates that make a free enterprise
system possible because people often
also think about only the market working
but you need a set of regulations and
also customs that'll that the free
market can run on top of like an
operating system exactly and i love that
you're using word operating system
because this is going to take us to
something else so so then but before we
go any further
there i want to point that as i was
learning from the work of people like
hernandez de soto
as i was learning from people like the
man who became my husband i like to joke
and say he brought me the answer to my
little girl's question i i rewarded him
with love so i married him
um as i was looking at the work of
people like him michael strong you know
uh people like john mack here of whole
foods market they're friends so that's
how i got to know john but they made me
really get into a whole nother world of
people who truly care but what was
different about these people is that
they cared
not on their own terms they cared but on
the terms of the truth and we might go
into that at some point but let me just
keep it there so there so what happened
in that time of my life
as i was trying to see how can i
how can i multiply my whatever success
i found out the answer i started to
connect with dots and i and i learned
that eventually
wow yeah wow so
you're poor because you have no money
no money because no source of income
a source of income for most of us is a
job where do jobs come from the private
sector
businesses especially smaller
medium-sized enterprises
then don't we shouldn't we think about
the environment of those businesses in
which they get to thrive or not
i think we do but then where when i look
there and i look at these indexes
they're all telling me one thing and one
thing only is
your region is a porous in the world
because it happens to be the most
over-regulated in the world meaning that
as many people fight for freedom and
supposedly fight for africa's rights no
one fought about one of the most
important of rights and freedoms
after you have managed human rights in
its you know global way
economic freedom
well you you list here in one of your
articles uh where you make reference to
these rating systems the bottom 10
countries for doing business in the
world chad haiti
central african republic congo
democratic republic south sudan libya
yemen venezuela there's a lovely example
eritrea and somalia and so there are
three exceptions in the african
ecosystem
mauritius rwanda kenya south africa
botswana and zambia you pointed out in
your prospectus is it prospectus yeah
the prospectus article of uh
right institute right that mauritius is
a rising star and rwanda is in some ways
comparable to georgia so some of these
countries have started to get this right
yes and so what's the consequence of
that and what does right mean
what they have understood what these
countries have understood is that
economic freedom
is at the center for prosperity building
uh ronda for example
paul kagame the president of rwanda
is explicit about it he said he wants to
be the lee kwang-woo of he wants to be
the singapore of africa
and li kuang wu is his model
now the dirty mouse are going to start
shouting oh yeah see authoritarian blah
blah blah whatever me i want to talk
only about the um on the economic side
if you take lee kuang wu and singapore
as your example
then it means that like him
you're gonna have to be serious about
economic freedom and that's exactly what
he did that's what singapore did when
singapore figured that out they went on
to put in the right reforms to make
their environment the most some of the
most business friendly environments in
the world one of the most free markets
environment in the world and you saw the
magic of singapore today singapore is
richer than its ex-colonizer great
britain so when i hear people telling me
today oh africa is poor because of
colonization i'm like please let's move
on from that
does it have maybe a tiny percentage in
where we are today maybe maybe and i
don't know but i know it's not the cause
because if it were many countless
countries have been colonized before and
by the way colonizing one another is is
humanity's history it just happened that
maybe african africa has been one of the
the last you know
colonized region in the world so enough
psyche it it is there and it acts like
nothing happened before to others but
uh flash news it's the history of the
world we've been capturing each other
back and forth all of that so anyway but
the truth is
um singapore
richer than great britain today and then
hong kong happened and then because hong
kong happened china even today happened
because china is like wait a minute what
kind what went on over there and then
china went on to do exact same thing
with its secs the special economic zones
some of the most free market zones in
the world and then look at it happen in
commerce china who when it comes to
economics decided that we're going to do
the free market we're going to be
capitalists because that's the only way
we tried everything else we killed
hundreds of millions of people
and we have and we have nothing to show
for it but now that we're tired of being
disrespected members of society because
guess what that's the other thing too
you want to be respected in this world
you're going to have to be among the mo
the prosperous ones for other reasons
would it be nice g that we respect
people just because absolutely but
that's really not the world we live in
so when china got tired of being
disrespected we're like maybe we've got
to build also some prosperity here
because then they're gonna hear us and
today china being one of uh you know
being where it is at even hollywood
hollywood who tries to tell the world
how to think is being told by china
what movies to make
and how to tweak stories and history in
order to be palatable for them you see
the power that comes with with being
prosperous
what would you recommend concretely to
countries like senegal to get the hell
out of the way let's say of the people
who would like you would try to would do
everything they could to try to make it
better i mean one of the things that
happened with india is india established
the indian institute of technology which
is a deadly engineering school and a
huge number of its graduates went to
silicon valley as you well know and many
of the successful indian graduates of
iat started to dump money back into
india and build uh uh capitalist
infrastructure there helped build a
capitalist infrastructure there so this
sort of thing can really take hold if
you were making recommendations to
governments who wanted to get on board
and stop being like chad heidi
central african republic congo south
sudan libya yemen and venezuela et
cetera what what concrete state steps
should they take from the bottom up to
get the hell out of the way exactly so
two things we've been doing uh because
i'm an i'm a practitioner as that's my
entrepreneurial journey i'm an
entrepreneur so i practice what i preach
uh but i also preach i preach for free
markets and so
when it comes to that i'm i'm
one of the hats that i wear is as the
director for the african center for
prosperity of the atlas network the
largest organization in the world of um
free market think tanks around the world
and so what we do there is we work on um
reforms around the world to take down
barriers of entry for local
entrepreneurs so that's one thing but as
we all know that's a great initiative to
take and we've been making some really
um good advances in uh in many countries
especially in ghana we've been making a
lot of progress with our partners very
many
but um piecemeal but that is piecemeal
legislation it takes forever it is hard
as heck and by the time you made a gain
here you made 20 losses over there and
it's a continuous problem but until we
get better we got to continue at it so
that's one thing we've been doing and so
that's a hat i wear working with free
market think tanks to try to make it
easier for and local entrepreneurs to to
to join in the party
uh additionally i'm going bold i'm going
radical for the past few years we've
been advocating um
an idea for africa that
found some of its roots in um in latin
america and again i'm related to the
people who are involved in this my
husband
one of the key figures in this movement
a movement called the charter cities
paul romero calls it like that he's a
nobel laureate in economics um obvious
calls it call it the free cities i like
to call it the startup cds so the best
way to think about it jordan and it goes
back to what you were talking about
earlier when you said when you use the
word operating software
most of the poor developing most of the
low-income nations so meaning
back in the days the way we used to call
it is poor nations
are
they have regulations for poverty
they're basically regulated for poverty
meaning the laws the set of law poverty
it only cause poverty
and so
what some of these folks have thought
about looking at the dubai example
dubai just recently entered the top ten
of international financial centers of
the world and what dubai did at some
point is think about it and be like on
this bare you know
sand
plot of sand that's technically worth
nothing right now as is
this 110 acres of land
sand everywhere they're like well maybe
sharia law is not the best for business
um we got to think about better set of
laws for business we're talking about
only about business not family law not
anything else but business and they
decided there's got to be something
better
and so they looked around and that's
actually when to take one of the terms
you used earlier they're starting to
realize
common law is actually a better way for
business specifically british common law
so at that point and i'm always
simplifying here because otherwise we
can totally geek out on it remember this
is like one of my latest things that
i've been involved in
but latest it's been the past 10 years
and i'm gonna share with you a win
um so dubai is like we have to
adopt british um you know common law
primarily british common law we're gonna
hire retired british common law judges
to come and educate the law here train
our own people
and that along with many other reforms
to also become a top center uh when it
comes to um
and the free market when it comes to the
finances
that british common law that british
common law system so it's very very
interesting
theologically and metaphysically so it's
predicated on the idea that people have
every individual has all the rights that
there are
except for those that are specifically
regulated and limited by legal necessity
and then generally that
that realm of necessity has emerged only
as a consequence of disputes between
people so you're free to do whatever you
want unless you have a dispute with
someone else then the dispute is
adjudicated according essentially to
constitutional and theological
principles and then a precedent is
established and then the whole body of
law built up that body of precedence yes
yeah and it's bottom up not top down
english common law is a gift from god
man it's something else absolutely and
that's the key word there when you said
bottom up so common law is so much
better for bottom-up approaches and we
all know that markets work better in a
bottom-up approach and also when they
have to educate the law and um resolve a
dispute they're going to be much more
respectful to the contract that was
passed between the two parties than say
civil law would be right and so anyway
so from this standpoint here you have
dubai who is now trying to put all of
this together and eventually they put a
set of laws together that would now be
conducive to being a top international
financial center in the world and voila
in less than a generation in less than
25 years dubai completely unrecognizable
completely but they did not invest in
that short period of time that's what i
know you know the the chinese the
purchasing power of the
average chinese citizen is doubling
every seven years yes everything is
right it's insane it's insane
so we know it can be done and at the
root of that is the same thing it's
economic freedom it's allow people the
freedom to enterprise and dubai did so
dubai was one of the most recent ones to
do it now the uae in general abu dhabi
is um going the same way and they're
even trying to
outbid each other in terms of who is
going to be even more free market uh so
that's something beautiful going on
there so people some folks have looked
at that model and then be like wow so
maybe uh let's think about a plot of
land ideally a rather unoccupied plot of
land so you're not you're not being
accused of uh mispla displacing people
or you know conscious conscious
confiscation any of that so english is
only my fourth language uh jordan so
sometimes if i stumble upon words plea
please be patient with me so anyway so
they thought about it and i said okay so
the plot of land think about it as your
computer and think about the laws that
rule that plot of land as your operating
software
and to start to think about governance
as a new frontier and so now what you
have is these governance entrepreneurs
and that's definitely where i have gone
into i'm like forget piecemeal
legislation we're going to keep doing
that until we have better but in the
meantime i'm working this radical idea
so for the past decade i've been working
on um
on
convincing
african governments to do this
and finally i can't disclose the name
today here but we've signed an mou a
month ago with one of uh western uh
african nations who said
yeah and it's funny because when we
approach them jordan congratulations
thank you it's a major achievement thank
you like a world shaking achievement
thank you and we have a top team to work
on this and so but it's so funny because
when we first met them
the gentleman said he said my god
what do you mean by common law because
you know they belong to a civil law like
many french um
ex-french colonies by the way you see
that's another difference when france
supposedly you know at the end of
colonizations of many african nations
the british the british um
you know um colonizers said you can do
whatever you want keep coming do
whatever you want whatever turns out
most of those countries kept the common
law and it's actually easier when you
are um
it's actually easier for an african
nation or any other nation or culture to
actually build on top of common law than
it is to build on top of civil law so
see english we should shout that from
the rooftops exactly agree with that
absolutely right man common law is
deadly is that uh civil law is deadly so
so yeah i said
that's okay that's okay uh so basically
what happened there is um so all of
these francophone countries are still
operating uh francophone african
countries are still operating on civil
law for most of them for most of them
and that world doesn't know about that
either just like when we started talking
to this country face like what do you
mean common law
isn't there only civil law that exists i
was like i almost fell
i almost fell over
and then even that you see because you
live in your world you take so many of
these understandings for granted because
remember i've been spending my life
asking about these questions and
drilling and drilling and really you
know learning and then even um the the
work of someone like george haiti uh
ghanaian economist who just passed away
but he's my intellectual father on all
of this and i will bring him up in a
minute so anyway so here they're like
whoa so when they discovered about oh
there's common law there's civil law
civil law happens to be so good for
business blah blah and all of us and so
now that's um so that's what we're
working on and i'm telling you jordan i
don't know where this project is going
to go
but even if we only make five steps with
it
the floodgates have been open i believe
that with all my heart because all you
need is for a door in here to open up
yeah and then yeah that's all you need
that's a major door the one in there all
you need so so these countries um who
are at the bottom of the economic
freedom index
what sort of ideas do you think possess
them
to constantly run interference in
relationship to people who are trying to
be entrepreneurial so i know one of the
things that one of the things that's
happened you know since the berlin wall
fell and the collapse of capitalism is
that because the people who were pushing
communist ideas are not quite as noisy
and horrible as they once were although
they're certainly making a comeback that
many countries around the world have
been freed up to try to have not the
worst economic policies they could
possibly design but there's still this
lingering resentment and hostility
towards entrepreneurial free market
capitalism especially at the local level
that you're describing that's
unbelievably toxic so what is it that's
possessing these countries that are at
the bottom of the economic freedom index
venezuela is a good example no you're
giving me a goosebumps by asking me this
question because you're by asking it
you're going to allow me to share
something that once again is also part
of a myth busting and something that is
totally unknown to people
and i'm gonna talk only for the case of
africa because i'm sure for latin
america um the situation might be
similar but uh let me just talk about
the case of africa because it is
it is uh it is a big continent enough
that it should matter
so and this is where the work of george
aide takes all of its power and
importance georgia it is a gunning
economist like i said passed away
recently but george gave me the last
piece to the queue of my answer because
once i discovered that we're poor
because of our lack of economic freedom
that's the reason why we're poor then my
next question was like but why why why
is it that americans get to enjoy this
academic freedom and we don't what
happened where did it happen
have we always been this is the mystery
well you know the thing it's really is a
mystery too because
it doesn't require much of an
explanation to explain poverty and
corruption right because we're born poor
because we don't come natural
and corruption is corrupt that's right
that's the natural state of man and so
the real mystery and this is a bloody
mystery that's for sure is how any
country ever managed to escape that and
the common law tradition is definitely a
piece of that and yeah of course america
was fortunate enough to be founded on
those principles and so okay so continue
if you want yes yes so
so yes so my question was just like
yours once i discovered i'm like
and still why is it because these people
have it and we don't what happened to us
what's going on and most impo so so but
now i'm understanding also this this uh
this battle between um socialism and
capitalism the ideologies and how
they're fighting each other and for some
bizarre strange reason
um the world including africans um
developed this idea this understanding
that we are more socialists and we're
capitalists naturally culturally i'm
like i'm like i called bs on that
because i called bs on that because you
say again the same africans you bring
them to a country where it's economic
freedom and voila let them manifest i
mean did you know that
most um black doctors in the in the us
are from nigeria
did you know that
right and that um yeah well i know that
immigrants i know that black immigrants
to the u.s do much better proportionally
speaking than black people who are born
in the u.s right so so where is that but
then i when i asked that question
it's when georgia and his work
brought me my find my answer and that
was the last piece of a puzzle and then
everything made sense okay we're our
region is the poorest in the world
because it's the most over-regulated
region in the world
how did we get there
george takes me back george takes me
back to a time that most people don't
think about including myself at first
because when most people think about the
story of africa africans and black
people in africa in general we go no
further down than slavery it seems like
our collective history starts with
slavery
and george is reminding us no no no
they were
they were before the white men ever set
foot on the continent
black people were there
they had different types of um you know
like many different cultures many
different uh society groups name it
yet
and then george made the case with his
research but actually
pre-colonial africans
were actually practicing the free
markets they were practicing free
enterprise and it makes sense but so
what what we were doing back then we in
africa you could find some of the most
sophisticated trade routes in the world
uh you would go to places like great uh
zimbabwe uh where where basically they
you would see these homes these um
buildings built in a round shape with
stone
whoever built that in those times was at
the top of their craftsmanship at the
top of engineering skill sets something
quite unbelievable
so unbelievable and advanced that when
the white people came they said there's
no way a black person black people could
have built this
you see so this is who we were
and and the chief the chief could never
say oh my god you made your bread now
you come to my and you're at the market
here you cannot sell it for one dollar
more profit than when i allow you to to
jordan
no such rubbish didn't exist with us
you had um basically also this idea that
we have to wait every four years or five
years to vote no we voted with our power
of exit and you could exit every second
that you wanted if you don't like this
chief and what he or she is practicing
vote with your feet get out you go join
another another group or you go
start another group you name it but
you're not going to sit and fight with
other people there just so that things
can go your way you go and make it
happen new way or you go join others who
are doing it your way and so for the
longest time what we had was tribes
maintaining the peace did we have
battles among us you betcha that again
human nature
but what was happening we were tribes
working with each other and keeping the
peace even knowing sometimes when to try
to intermarry so that we even keep the
peace more
and then they came and they said oh gee
aren't you guys
savages and we're gonna civilize you and
to civilize you is we're gonna bring
this top-down governance approach to all
of us see we were practicing
decentralized governance before and they
showed up and they said to be educated
is to have centralized governance what
did you do when you do that now the
tribes are fighting among each other
to take control of that centralized
govern government
there's a real tension there because
it's very difficult it's very
advantageous obviously for people to be
enmeshed together in large-scale groups
like the united states 320 million
people but then the question is how do
you put in all the subsidiary levels of
organization so that just doesn't become
a monolithic state right and then the
question too is well how do you
introduce that
large-scale integrated governance
without absolutely demolishing the micro
societies that make up part of it and
bring people together without undue
bloodshed right it's a real catastrophic
problem from a historical perspective it
really is it really is so
so so then uh so when we went to go back
to the story we go from yeah we go from
having tribes to now tribalism
because of his introduction so anyway
uh so when they started when they came
they said to us um
so so okay so all of that was going on
and then eventually we were living our
lives minding our own business doing
fine and i and i would argue that if we
have been left alone we probably would
be ver more ex the richest um
continent in the world today if we had
continued but we didn't continue slavery
happened after slavery colonialism
happened
uh
at the end of colonism this is where i
would like to bring the attention of
people because that's that's what george
that's what george is so well so
beautiful and pointing
just around the time when most african
nations were getting their independences
starting with ghana
we were talking about the late 50s early
60s remember also what was happening
back then we were at the height
of a battle between these two ideologies
right on one end represented by the
freedom
and the economic practice was capitalism
and on the other uh facing off with um
various forms of statism
socialism communism and primarily prac
their practice was you know they were
socially more communism and they were at
like this with each other
around that time we're getting our
independence
and you know what they said
at that point
remember try to put yourself back in
those times because it's so important
you have these great liberators of
africa
who have fought
for liberation we're talking about
rollins of uh ghana we're talking about
uh julius nireire we're talking about um
people like thomas sankara later down
the road
were talking about these people right
and they have fought
they have fought for the liberation of
this continent they have given it
everything they had
and when uh but what we don't remember
so what happened with these people is
like oh so now these two these two
ideologies are fighting and it looks
like we have to take a side because
the two idols are fighting we're looking
for influence and we're looking for
instruments south right so
and everybody's talking about africa was
trying to africa was trying to free
itself from domination by we were at
least normally the capitalist west and
that's always the idea that the enemy of
my enemy is my friend right that's
exactly and that didn't work out so well
with the communists no and this is where
we made the fatal mistake because at
that point as we were looking for
influence us africans freshly liberated
and i put quotation marks because i'm
not sure we have been liberated freshly
liberated
is saying look
you
west is who
enslaved me first then colonized me i am
certainly not gonna party up with you so
we're gonna go in kahoot with the with
um the eastern you know with the not so
free side
and this is when they have been spending
all of their times with the marxist
socialists of their times
and this is also times around which
w.e.b dubois
did the dirty work he didn't think it
was dirty work but he is the one who
helped all of these
soon-to-be leaders of liberated african
nations
to really bite into these ideas because
by then they had conflated
slavery
with capitalism with imperialism with
colonial common law with everything for
them the whole darn thing was one big
evil to throw out of the water and so
they they threw the baby out of the bath
water
and when they did that they had totally
forgotten
their own indigenous roots because
pre-colonial africans practiced for free
markets pre-colonial africans would have
looked at this marxist socialist and
said this is heresy you guys are crazy
this is not even part of our roots we
are rejecting this with everything we've
got
but it did not happen that way no so
this is how
liberated nations of africa
got started on the wrong foot went to
bed with the wrong people and six years
later we have nothing to show for it
because we all know what happens to
people who follow the socialist route
this this does fit in nicely with our
earlier comments about venezuela because
venezuela has taken exactly the same
route and gone from a rich
and and
post-colonial country to an absolute
bloody nightmare in about 30 years and
it's also a consequence of
of that entire country falling under the
toxic dominion of these ideas but you
can certainly understand
why that would have been attractive to
the emergent african countries of the
1960s right i mean yeah it is a hard
thing to think through
the idea that the enemy of my enemy is
not necessarily my friend and a lot of
these marxist ideas which purport to
have the poor in mind but which truly
don't are extremely attractive even if
you are
heartfelt in your consideration for the
poor the problem is is that the only
systems that seem to
lift people out of absolute poverty are
free market capitalist systems and
they're and their
equivalent the kind of equivalent you
describe characterizing pre-colonial
africa that's right and that's why it's
so important for me whenever i bring up
this part of a story to always that's
why i was saying please try to put
yourself back in their shoes back in
those days because i believe that if i
had lived in those times hey i would
have been part of the people who fight
for african liberation and i probably
would have made the same decision
to side with a social with a marxist
socialist i would have i think i would
well half the western world made that
decision and the chinese made that
decision and the north koreans made that
decision i mean exactly
and now we're having a battle about the
same damn ideas again as i said they
have invaded the west again that's the
thing but this is where i as an african
will not have it
um while i'll i excuse i think the
mistake they made was fatal for us but
hopefully it's a mistake that would have
had consequences for only this 60 or 62
plus years
since it's we took those we made those
decisions
uh but today i take it upon my
responsibility
as a contemporary african you know to
know better
and on top of that i also know the ways
of my pre-colonial fathers which to me
now are the only ones i want to look at
are pre-colonial favors of course is it
that everything they did was right no
this is why you know we have progress in
life right there are some things we know
now we're not so good but we are some
things that have to pass the test of
time and place so maybe first we should
keep so anyway so as an african living
today with everything that i know and is
available to know everywhere the
research is very clear the the evidence
is is rock solid i cannot in
in uh in uh with
in in all consciousness and
uh be a
person of high morality i cannot
disregard what i have learned and what i
have experienced and what by now we know
to be true so people like me
marxist socialists need to know for the
longest time they have used us for black
people to make their dirty deeds so
maybe the black lives matter people the
founders who are self called marxist
um social marxists
fine if they want to go i i say find it
i'm not fine i'm not fine yeah but if
they want to if they want i'm not
willing to be the useful idiot
idiot of a social of a social marxist
any longer they have used us black
people for too long they have used us
suffering for too long but today i know
better to dissociate myself and so
they're going to have to go look for
other peons to to to to to to you know
to to mess their heads with but because
people like me i know the truth and what
i love about the truth that i had
learned is that my pre-colonial
forefathers
totally would have
stood by
my um devotion to the free enterprise
they would have said
great great great
granddaughter thank you
thank you for looking back to our times
and seeing what we were doing we were no
more we were on the right track girl we
were so today i think everybody has to
make a decision from himself but me what
i have learned that's what i'm taking
out and everything we talked about today
jordan
is really not part of a mainstream
because you asked most people african
included why are you poor they're gonna
say colonism they're gonna say racism
they're gonna say because they're taking
all of our uh natural resources and blah
blah blah and so on and so forth and
guess what
those who claim to care in the west
they leave us in that
misguided
opinion of what the problem is
because it took me
so long i was with these people who said
that they cared about me they cared
about africa
but as soon but i found that every time
that they hear that the solution might
be
for free markets and capitalism
the look of
disgust i think that's the right word
the look of disgust but they have in
their face
if i was not stronger i would feel
disgusted by myself for having those
opinions
so do you really care or do you only
care when
the solution that you're peddling
goes to support
your own ideology
yeah and your and your own moral claims
yes to care yes right because that's the
easy way out it's like well i care and
there's some people who are well off and
those people who are well off have
stolen everything they have from the
oppressed people and i'm on the side of
the oppressed people and all i have to
do is punish the oppressors and all of a
sudden i'm a moral agent yeah and i can
leverage the suffering of genuine poor
people whom we know have actually been
helped out of their absolute poverty by
capitalist systems we absolutely know
that to be the case i can leverage their
suffering to bestow onto me an
undeserved moral superiority that's
right and then i can have my cake and
eat it too because i can still be a
denizen of the wealthy west but and i
can feel sorry for poor people and be
oppressed at the same time absolutely
and i feel like you're even being too
generous for them in terms of the work
they put in because today
that i care the only way it manifests
itself in
work into action
i put a sign on my on my back on my yard
with black lives matter period done
if black lives matter so much
if black lives matter so much then
you cannot with a straight face
tell me in the same sentence
that you also are anti-capitalists
and also if black lives matter so much
what do you make of a fate of 1 billion
black people because africa is home to 1
billion black people with 1.3 billion
but 1 billion of those are black
it is home to ninety percent of a
representative of a black race
yet to tell me black lives matter
and you in the same sentence are going
to be anti-capitalist the only thing we
know to build prosperity and with that
respect
huh
you cannot be possibly serious here
and guess what flash new news flash
people like me today are here to tell
you how full of it you are because
you're full of it and i'm not going to
allow you to no longer have your cake
and eat it too
it's just too easy
when the steaks are so high and the same
thing with your whole thing about the
climate change oh gee climate change i'm
not even gonna go and argue
the
the scientific um
you know argument
i'm not
let's say i even agree with you but
the world is gonna go to hell in 12
years as they claim if nothing is done
earth is going to blow up in 12 years
let's go and freak out all the kids
because you know what it's it's
justified
let's say i even agree with you on that
one and then i say
and then we do what because your
solution right now is to tell me we stop
all carbon emission we stop all fossil
fuels right now
right now
but jordan what does that mean if we did
that what does that mean if we did that
it means it means poor people will
freeze in the dark and bake in the sun
while they starve thank you you just
signed a death
warrant
and i'm going to talk about africa only
for now you just signed a death warrant
for 1.3 billion people of them one
billion black people and you just told
me that black lives matter
so even when you come to climate you're
full of it
and i'm willing to say that you're just
an idiot because you don't know what's
going on but but even there and if you
still with a straight face can say yeah
well to sacrifice the rest of the world
uh i'm sorry to sacrifice um these 1.3
billion africans so that the left the
earth can can stay
oh really
how different are you event from
somebody who enslaved me a little while
ago does my really my life is worth that
black black babies are going to have to
die so your white babies can stay alive
you know sometimes when i hear the
prince um who is that guy's name you
know the princess diana had two kids i
think uh the older one he
with a straight face the guy popped by
the time he had popped child number four
had the nerves to tell us that the
problem with the world is overpopulation
earth cannot sustain uh overpopulation
from the guy who has four kids so what
are you telling me exactly because i'm
just you know marianne toopey marion
toopey from humanprogress.org publishing
a book in august called
super abundance and he's redone a number
of economic calculations showing for
example documenting the extremely
positive relationship between increased
population and general prosperity that's
right and he calculated that every child
born today
will produce
seven times as many resources as he or
she will consume see
right c is right and so all these people
who are squawking about there being too
many people on the planet
and there's always other people who are
too many that's what i was pointing out
absolutely so here's prince whatever his
name is telling me that the problem with
the world is overpopulation while just
having popped his fourth child so are
you telling me that your child can live
but the other ones cannot because that's
pretty much what you're saying because
you popped these kids
and if that's what you're saying if
you're saying that the oven that's the
other ones cannot cannot then go on keep
going with your thinking wow yeah right
you can't say why can't they why can't
they are you a closeted racist maybe not
but we're gonna we're gonna see this
we're gonna see this play out in the
fall this is coming just as certain as
as the sun's going to rise tomorrow you
know the fact these environmental
policies that have emboldened putin made
europe dependent on oil and gas from
russia that's right now we have a
shortage and we have a huge increase in
fertilizer prices and we know perfectly
well that about 150 million people most
of them in africa and in and in in north
africa and in the middle east and in
sub-saharan africa are going to be
suffering dreadfully in the fall because
of this and so we can see right away
that what has happened when push came to
shove is that the radical utopian
marxist types who are beating the drum
about the environment were perfectly
willing to sacrifice today's real poor
to the hypothetical well-being of some
future poor in their utopian schemes
absolutely and that's coming right away
no it's coming right away and then what
i what i what i've what
one of the things that the ukrainian war
has brought up to the surface because
we've been talking about it forever but
and then people like oh you're being too
um you're not being you know
but it's the hypocrisy of these people
the hypocrisy
when i have a green party of all parties
the green party of germany
i don't know if you heard it
a week or so ago they came out and they
said oh we have to keep burning coal for
a little while longer oh really yeah
when you are online we have to keep
burning cold a little while longer oh
but no but the africans no
no so this hypocrisy is gonna the
reckoning is coming the reckoning is
coming because i for one i'm not willing
to stand there and let them get away
with it all of this time they made it
sound like they have a moral high ground
and i call you not only that's enough of
that i agree man
that's such a lie i call bs i'm gonna
call them what they are these these uh
anti-fossil fuel zealots
are the new racists of our times
and we can see clear in their game and
we will not stand for it
not
so
uh a war is coming but the war that's
coming for me is not a cultural war i
think the cultural war is too easy for
them to to take to to win in a way but
this one right here is going to bring
them straight back to who they are
um when i see that um
jeff bezos ex-wife
gave a couple hundred million dollars to
planned parenthood and she specifically
earmarked it
for black women
lady can you please tell me if uh
you're further thinking and we didn't
hear about it by the way in the bigger
news
so i'm just trying to understand why
does the world think that it needs less
black babies it seems to me that's what
it is so
they
we want to talk about racism i think
there is racism here that doesn't speak
its name
but we're gonna have to call it what it
is so it's gonna be one thing or another
uh jordan one is you're gonna have to
i'm gonna hold you you have to tell me
that
black lives matter if black lives matter
when african lives have to matter if
african lives do matter
then capitalism matters
and if you make that case we're good
let's go let's get this fossil fuels
matter and fossil fuel
and so people can burn
clean burning fuels in their house
instead of choking their children to
death on indoor pollution
so you're going to have to tell me that
all of that matters if black lives
matter then it means um one billion
african black african lives do matter
which means capital matter which means
fossil fuels matters
if not you're telling me that
it doesn't
because and and you don't have to tell
me black lives don't matter for you to
tell me it doesn't matter all you have
to tell me is
we can't have fossil fuels
and we can't have capitalism if you tell
me that then i know that de facto black
lives did not matter for you and if
black lives did not matter for you then
you're racist done
you want to go through this whole like
white supremacist vase and blah blah
blah
today if you are not in favor of what is
going to contribute to my human
flourishing
as a black person
forget white supremacy whatever you want
to call it that to me is the new
definition of racism
that's a really good that's a really
good place to end i would say this part
of the discussion i want to talk to you
a little bit more we're going to do this
on the daily wire plus
network and i want to talk to you a
little bit more about your personal
experiences but i really want to thank
you for having this conversation with me
today and i think it'll i hope as you
said it'll break up a lot of these
they're not just myths they're toxic
anti-truths
and they're hurting people in a way that
we're just beginning to become aware of
and there's going to be all hell break
loose this fall yes so and i'm really
sad and sorry about that because it was
completely unnecessary as you as you
know we know the pathway forward common
laws are that's just that's such a
firm foundation to
build a prosperous society upon a proper
free enterprise localized economy get
the bureaucrats and the resentful people
the hell out of the way of people like
you and see if we can get prosperity to
grow everywhere in the world then maybe
two when people get rich enough they'll
be able to afford to care about the
environment a little bit instead of
having to be forced into an anti-carbon
environment by these idiot
environmentalists z-lots that's what i
call it also the disrespect of a poor
it's it's just absolutely total
disrespect for the poor thinking that
you're superior to them do you think you
superior to them just because you care
about the air that you breathe gee i
think you would be just like this poor
person if you had no food in your belly
child is sick you don't know how you're
gonna take care of it um you you had all
of these issues that come straight from
your poverty i think that you two the
quality of the air you breathe or the
quality of the water you drink might be
um number 100 in the priority list
because right now you have to survive so
for you to think that something is wrong
with them because they don't care about
that well maybe i'll put you in that
position and we'll see when you're going
to start to think about that and so this
is complete disrespect for the poor and
it is unacceptable it is wrong
great i agree with you one hundred
percent
all right that's great so
very thank you very much for talking
thank you for having much appreciate it
was very good to see you again thank you
i would encourage you to continue
listening to my conversation with my
guest on dailywireplus.com